well tickets are now available for the  animal foundation's best in show this is  adorable it's a great fundraising event  that they do every year the event is may  1st it's at the thomas and mack tickets  oh my gosh they're only five dollars  kids under five get in on for free and  you can also bid on a chance to adopt  one of these adorable doggies featured  in the event  one of those look like a cross between a  german shepherd and a corgi oh my  goodness i know with the little legs and  then this one hello just post still  we're working on our manners still we're  working there oh this is such a great  job yeah that's a fun one we love going  to it